[Music]
hey
yo guys i was gonna say y'all but then i
thought you'd be like
yeah esther says howdy hey you guys
happy sunday how's your weekend going
tom just letting nike not even get a
contribution
well i didn't i was way off the side way
off the side of the damn camera
what the [ __ ] is up with this camera
well pookie was in here [ __ ] around
i introduced her to i forgot i bought
one of those like uh
those gloves you know that pulls all
their hair out and stuff yeah
and i pulled it out when she was in here
like [ __ ] around on my desk and i
did that and she was like oh this is the
best thing ever
yeah and she was just kind of like
i took like a bunch of hair out too you
know you know today we're gonna do
um show on uh like recommendations of
southern food classic southern food that
those you who have never lived in the
south or maybe in other countries you
know
[ __ ] that you know you may want to try
and it's all simple
the recipes can be found online don't go
for the fancy recipes you go
go for the damn common ones that's the
one that's the ones we eat
you know [ __ ] that's just typical which
will give you a baseline on what these
foods are supposed to taste like
it's all pretty much comfort food it's
all inexpensive to make
that's one of the reasons why they ended
up being southern classics you know food
kind of comes from necessity
made out of the things that are around
in this area linked up with traditions
that we have on how things are supposed
to taste it's good
it's good now is this [ __ ] healthy no
[ __ ] no
no hell no
[Laughter]
cooked in bacon grease everything is
buttered everybody's got butter
cheese cheese sugar cream
cream bacon fan yeah it's rice
potatoes grits you know
you're basically eating wallpaper paste
you know you're you're eating and not
wallpaper paste but you're eating glue
it's something that turns into glue when
it goes in you very starchy
not all the time you can get around it
you know you can control it through
portion control
um there are kind of like rich man
versions of these recipes where yeah
they can be
elevated you can elevate them um
but it's good stuff and we're going to
start off with a list
of uh real common foods that we
will uh do a quick description of what
they are and
answer any questions you guys might have
about them tila said still recovering
from the epic friday night stream
right i mean holy crap i can't believe
that went on the team
sam you weren't here
well the reason that we had because we
went out last night
so um saw chantal too yeah we went and
saw chantal she was there actually she
was there
tonight yeah because all their all their
bikes were out there
so we didn't have a chance to watch a
movie so i said well let's just do a
food show
on sunday and because we were at
chantal's and we had gotten
chicken and waffles yeah i said well
let's just do a southern food show
because we usually end up talking about
that anyway but i feel like we could
maybe
little boston was working there she
[ __ ] rounds up well boston little bus
that's what i'm calling i can't remember
her name
katie it's katie yeah katie with a c
yeah with a c-a-i-t-y i just call her
little
boston she's a little girl from boston a
little white girl works for
for sean telstra thanks for putting in
for a good word for me she she said you
said you spoke highly of me
so yeah yeah you're a good waitress
she's right yeah yeah i
thought you know chantal's trying to get
a good front of house
like i had to put in a complaint about
what happened for me and jenny
going there man we sat down and nobody
even asked us for our order or drink
and he only had two two tops at a three
top out front
and i heard the cooks in there [ __ ]
scrambling but front of house was just
sitting there [ __ ]
looking in there falling around 15
minutes later it's a [ __ ] let's go
and i said chantelle i had to give your
money to mcdonald's and she you gave
that [ __ ] to mcdonald's
[ __ ] mcdonald's i said i know i
wanted to give it to you but i gave it
to mcdonald's
and she but she goes i know exactly she
goes those girls are gone i fired them
yeah yeah because i guess we weren't the
only ones the only ones that had
complained about it
yeah but i mean it's it's so good like
to eat [ __ ] chicken i mean they like
i said the limited menu
you know in the middle of the night um
you know so again they didn't have
french fries last night because they had
run out they ran out
so i was gonna get you know fish and
chips but i was like well if they don't
have french fries i'm just gonna get
chicken and waffles
again i couldn't eat it all but god damn
it was so good we had chicken waffles
yeah we both had that will was there
streaming his [ __ ] girlfriend well he
streams his girlfriend live over his
[ __ ] necklace
wherever he goes it's so funny he's in
the army barracks she got
deployed to kuwait yeah so she's in
kuwait she was there was like her
she's a major in the army yeah she's
medical staff
it's just funny yeah so so will i don't
know what he got to he was oh he was
getting fish but then he had cake also
he had red velvet cakes
and yeah he buys her red velvet cake and
carrot cake which that should be on the
list because
red velvet cake is a southern classic it
is i love
love red velvet cake i love carrot cake
also actually pretty much any kind of
cake is good
now chicken and waffles is catching on
tila said how was the chicken and
waffles yeah their chicken and waffles
is like
delicious what's good about it is that
um
uh her her staff does not overcook any
of this stuff so the chicken comes out
it's [ __ ] hot and juicy
if it's fish it's cooked just right it's
not it doesn't get it's not dry
same thing with uh shrimp they
they cook shrimp to perfection shrimp
should have a certain pop to it
you know if it overcooks it becomes hard
like a bullet
you don't want that so they don't
overcook things which used to be kind of
a problem with
southern food and soul food which
there's a lot of crossover
that was mostly our parents and
grandparents generation that overcooked
things though
it was for safety reasons yes especially
pork chops like i said
i was talking about this you know in the
cookbook i was like
when i was growing up i always i was
always like oh are having pork chops for
dinner
i thought i didn't like pork chops for
like a really long time because they
were always overcooked and he was afraid
of trichosis
yeah but the older generations you could
give a southerner or a black person for
that for that matter you can give them a
perfectly good pork tenderloin and they
just [ __ ] cook it into [ __ ] shoe
leather
yeah which is a shame yes pork chops
when cooked correctly are you delightful
same thing with same thing with beef um
they would cook [ __ ] so well you could
give them a flamin yawn and they cook
that [ __ ] well done
like no no
no it's like darth vader
why are you ruining it yeah yeah flaming
yawn is always medium rare well the
thing about
it is that i mean even as a kid i was
always like a real i want
i'm a rare [ __ ] i want like some
rare ass meat even hamburgers steaks
everything
so it's like my so my grandma would get
very very gross out like if
we were having steaks or whatever and
i'm just like just run a match under
that [ __ ]
yeah i don't know why i just really
really like she's like it's so gross
look at like the blood and everything
there's a certain element of me
a certain element of southern culture
that's paranoid if anything's rare or
medium rare they go oh it's got blood in
it
and uh you know same thing with african
americans too you know but
no so high quality cuts of meat should
be
medium rare or rare uh it's cooked it's
just
it should it should give off a little
bit of aju we just cooked but it's
juices but it's like a gravy you know
yeah and um if it's if if you have to
cook that [ __ ] well done
you're really cooking it well done
because it's a bad piece of meat
it's something tough you know so you
have to [ __ ] over braise it or
[ __ ] slow cook it till it
becomes tender you know that's it's a
safety thing
or it's um because it's a low quality
cut of meat
anything high quality it's medium rare
or rare
well yeah because you can't that's why
you paid that extra money well yeah i
mean you want to be able to like taste
the meat and like
marbling and everything like that you
can't like make it all [ __ ] tough and
everything you're just doing in it
yeah and that another thing that a lot
of southerners did too
was they would uh they would boil
vegetables oh yeah
to death until it became paste until it
was just like it kind of lost all the
flavor and stuff like that so like i
said for a long time when i was a kid
too i didn't think that i liked spinach
or broccoli
or anything like that just because gee
you've had it raw yeah until until
you've eaten a rot like the one time
like i ate spinach raw like in a salad
and i was like oh my god this is really
good i just i hated it when i was a kid
because it was like so [ __ ]
my fly my first positive experience with
spinach was
in a wilted spinach salad yeah which you
just take spinach and you [ __ ] cook
it in bacon grease and
it's bacon grippings bacon bits and vin
and i think it was red wine vinegar yeah
i think it might have a slight touch of
sugar in it and uh and then the things
that i forgot what else went and went
inside
wilted salad and you just toss it and it
just slightly wilts and it's a warm
salad it's [ __ ] great it is with a
little slide of vinegar
i haven't had in a long time makes you
want to make it now that would be
spinach salad man bacon bacon makes
everything better yeah
okay that's that's one thing the
southerners got right like as they cook
everything in bacon grease yeah that's
when i used to like go
uh you know when i'd stay at my mom's
house and stuff like that and she always
made
fried eggs and bacon grease and yeah
pancakes and bacon grease and everything
like that
that's like it is chiming and going yeah
over cooking until all the nutrients
have evaporated and it's just [ __ ]
filling the belly and
powder yeah and then you're leaving by
all you're leaving behind all the
nutrients in the damn water that you
boiled
in yeah and then half the time they
threw that [ __ ] out the other half the
time you keep it is pot liquor
yeah cook something else in it but which
you know is
pot liquor is just a southern southern
term for
um broth i guess you could say yeah it's
just the broth like whatever after you
cook
it whether it's meat or vegetables or
whatever yeah
and a lot of times well sometimes you
can like i said you can make if you make
collard greens or something like that
like a lot of times they'll
keep that so they can make like a little
sauce with it yeah product
so let's go ahead and go through the
list let's see
um what you got a list pulled up over
there i do actually
okay this is one you just picked this
one because the wikipedia part one is
like too complicated
right so like forgive how they want yeah
the wikipedia one wants to go through
regions in this thing
it's a wikipedia particle regions is a
factor but
but it for jet for general consumption
it's just the top ones matter the most
really yeah what's the most popular
because it's popular not only in our
region
which is just the south people outside
the regions would like it too and
there's certain [ __ ] that people in
other countries
and other regions just not gonna like
like chitlins and [ __ ]
you know chitlins [ __ ] stink the
entire house up they're good you gotta
clean them properly they gotta be boiled
and then deep a lot of southerners don't
like chickens either yeah so you know
what i mean they are very
divisive and it was uh
because it was a thing of necessity they
were around
it's like yeah it's it's pork and large
intestines from a pork
pig pig intestines um not a lot there
to work with but nowadays you can have
them kind of like you'd have chicken
wings
you know a big plate of them [ __ ]
fried and the dip you know that's really
the
only way i would ever eat something like
that they'd have to be done right
yeah yeah i mean because uh some
chipmunks are [ __ ] oh
no i wouldn't eat that just smell it
[ __ ]
20 feet away yeah i'm like that's
nature's way of telling you not to eat
that not that but um
[Laughter]
yeah esther said bacon should be its own
food group yeah yeah i think it is
it might as well be it's at the top of
the food pyramid yeah
it's uh it's it makes everything good
yeah you just put bacon on everything
tila says i hate any canned vegetable i
grew up with canned green beans
yeah i hated it once i had fresh sauteed
green beans i was hooked thrown some
garlic yeah
exactly and green beans are the damn
generic canned
food for all times if you pick a random
can out of a pile of [ __ ] canned food
probably green bean and you don't want
it yeah it's always kind of like i mean
whenever you have like the southern
dinner whatever you always have like a
meat dish
so you have like pork chops or whatever
you always had a starch
which was usually potatoes of some kind
mashed potatoes scallop potatoes
whatever
and then you just for health reasons
you'd have a couple sides usually green
beans and
corn but it was always out of a can yeah
pretty much and it was
that's because that's what was available
yeah and that shit's retro as [ __ ] that
goes back to the 40s and the 50s
and that was something that your
grandmother still thought was good she
was giving it to you
yeah and the idea of a fresh green bean
they weren't even sure that those
existed you mean they don't come in
cannons
i'm actually lying down that's not a
good story because
they also [ __ ] grew butter beans and
green beans out in the backyard we had
fresh green beans sometimes
because i remember like you know
shelling beans and beans and stuff like
that with my grandma but we usually had
cans
most working class southerners
doesn't matter if they're white or
they're black [ __ ]
mississippi alabama florida panhandle
kentucky central and northern louisiana
they descend from sharecroppers
sharecropping families
um and uh
even when sharecropping was not a
a profitable business you couldn't
really sell it they did it on the side
to have extra food so when you saw the
house out in the back was [ __ ] garden
it might have corn it might have
watermelons they just say well why not
because they know how to do it so they
just were getting free food
you know and particularly in this
climate it's like really easy to grow
[ __ ] especially like tomatoes pretty
much everybody i knew had at least some
tomatoes
somewhere in the yard so it was like
handed down as family traditions now
all that kind of started to go away
in the 80s later part of the 80s it
started to fade away
where a more mainstream
middle class type expectations started
to
kind of supplant the idea that every
house had to have a damn [ __ ] garden
behind it with food
who knows might come back because i'll
tell you what they survived
uh depressions and civil wars and
[ __ ] ethnic conflict
they were living like that for [ __ ]
200 years more
actually you know because some of that
[ __ ] predated the united states
back when spain controlled most of this
area they were they that's how everybody
pretty much lived there
you had your normal job and then you
grew food
you know you did it both at the same
time you might be a blacksmith but you
also grew food
or your wife was out there growing that
was like yeah women worked women worked
they just didn't work in a corporate
environment they worked because they
were [ __ ]
taking care of kids and growing food
[ __ ] fixing [ __ ] maintaining things
the
guy might be out might be a blacksmith
might be building wagon wheels
or he might be running around you know
executing some kind of contract
everybody worked there was no such thing
as not working everybody [ __ ] well
she had [ __ ] tons of money unless you
were [ __ ] super rich
and the south was kind of a lot like up
until very recently
and they post post [ __ ]
reconstruction okay the southern culture
was a lot like feudal japan
you know pl it was dominated by
plantations
and big business owners a lot of them
came and originally from the north they
were like our equivalent to the daimyo
everybody else was like some kind of a
peasant um
but it was like the wild west at the
same time too
but uh the way the the way the
the way the society was organized it was
kind of structured along
the lines of a [ __ ] agriculture a lot
like japan
a lot like feudal japan so
the people were kind of looked were like
that too you grew food and you worked
for somebody and you went back home and
you grew food
and this is the food that came up with
basically that evolved into this
do you want to just go buy this list
just go buy that list because i think
the first one's a dessert
okay it's fine peach cobbler peach
cobbler
peach cobbler's been made going back
probably the 40s 30s maybe
canning peaches probably goes back to
canning peaches and we could probably
look back to when they started doing
that that might have been 20s or 30s
actually
which means that they were making it
back then prior to refrigeration
things were canned peach survived the
canning process pretty well
and you can make a fantastic dessert
just in any kind of oven
you don't even need temperature control
you can make a peach cobbler
um the recipes are easy to find
usually what it is is most of them are
now based in self-rising flour
you mix a few ingredients together um
put it in the bottom of a pan
usually the pan's been buttered and then
pour a couple of cans of peaches along
with the syrup on it
put it in the oven and the the breading
rises up
out of the of all that swamp of peaches
and peach
juice to make a crispy
covering on the top of it of lightly
browned
cake basically and it's usually got
cinnamon and sugary you know
and it's you just take a dab spoon and
scrape some of it off and you put it
into a bowl and put some whipped cream
on top of it
or vanilla ice cream or vanilla ice
cream especially when it's hot
okay you want hot cobbler with
cold whipped cream or vanilla ice cream
on it
that's a southern [ __ ] classic is it
good
hell yes it's good hell yes very easy
and inexpensive to make
it is i thought well nowadays we um when
my grandma made it she always made it
with bisquick
and canned peaches yeah so bisquick i
think there might even be a recipe on
the side you can do it with berries too
um but yeah you would so
did you want to talk about red velvet
cake a little bit like what was like
no but like while we're on yeah well i
don't really know
you know what i mean you don't really
know much about that right well i do but
it's like i don't really know like how
to
red velvet cake is a heavy cake that's
easy to make
comes with a white frosting on it i
think it's normally sour cream or
sorry cream cheese based frosting on it
it's red because usually there's tomato
paste in it
or sometimes just ketchup and there's a
bunch of different recipes for it
or red food coloring i think it's more
common nowadays
[Laughter]
most people will tell you that the ones
with tomato in it is is the best
yeah it sounds weird like putting
ketchup or tomato sauce and cake but
it's
it does actually work it doesn't make
your cake taste like tomatoes no it
doesn't taste like tomatoes at all but
what it does
is it gives a a deep red
color to it almost kind of like a
purplish color
and it's very moist and very [ __ ]
heavy real good now not as [ __ ] moist
to say like
uh like uh
it's like an angel food cake but it's
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] dark red and there'll be
some moisture to it it's rich
really good and it's kind of like a
little bit of a chocolatey
chocolatey kind of a taste taste to it
yeah but not quite i don't think there's
any chocolate in it not quite like a
chocolate cake but it tastes kind of
like chocolate kind of like a chocolate
cake yeah and i love the frosting on it
yeah
it mixes with that frosting real well oh
yeah big time
but uh yeah so that's another one i feel
like that's kind of a popular that's
gotten
real popular especially like after that
big cupcake explosion
yeah okay now deviled eggs all right
well there was fried chicken but then
yeah okay everybody knows about fried
chicken fried chicken's a southern
classic
okay and that's all common around the
world the only difference
for us would be maybe like the seasoning
blends that would be
in the uh the uh the flour that you're
gonna roll the chicken in that would be
the only
difference is whether or not it's d you
know deep fried or pan fried
we don't normally deep fry it in the
same way we're like you know what i mean
where you're
with a whole deep fryer basket like you
do in a restaurant no it's usually just
in like a
inch of oil in a pan maybe a half inch
of oil flip it over
that's usually how we do it and some
there's i think there's uh
different ways that people do it because
some people will season the chicken
and not the breading or some people will
do the breading and not the chicken
some people do both things yeah you know
what i mean so it just kind of depends i
guess i'm like what kind of [ __ ] egg
wash and then you just roll it
and and flour that's been seasoned the
basic flat seasoning would just be you
know salt and pepper
a lot of people with salt and pepper
with cajun seasoning
salt and pepper with maybe cayenne salt
and pepper was something that would be
kind of like uh would give it that
kind of like the colonel sanders
original recipe which is gonna have
probably stuff like um i think there
might be some
uh [ __ ] what do you think i think
there's some sage in there i'm going to
say i think it's
there's some yeah it's some trade
secrets it's a trade secret
i'm sure someone has replicated it
pretty close you can just look at look
it up oh yeah big time
deviled eggs would be the next one that
was just like a real
common summertime
snack that uh
something like a grandma would make you
hard-boiled an egg cut them in half
take the yolks out put them all in a
bowl mix it up with a little bit of um
what do you call it mayonnaise and a
little bit of mustard whip it
there's some other seasonings that you
can put in there and then you take that
then take a spoon and just
ladle it back into the damn eggs or if
you wanted to be
if you wanted to be fancy you could put
it in one of those like frosting
yes like spray it and make it all
because that's how my grammy's yeah
now there's a you can cheat though you
can take you can take uh
all your egg mixture or whatever you're
filling
and put it in a ziploc bag knock all the
air out of it and take scissors and cut
the corner of it out and you can just
squeeze it in there now
that's the same thing make it a pastry
bag yeah you can do it with a ziploc bag
i mean essentially faster i remember
like every time we had a big
do like over at my grandmother's house
which you like thanksgiving and
christmas and stuff
you always had to have a platter of
deviled eggs yeah with
you know paprika yeah on them and you
always had to have a pickle tray
yeah and then you had the sour pickles
on one side and the sweet pickles on the
other side
there might be pickled cauliflower and
pickled pickled slices of uh what do you
call them little carrots and stuff
maybe pimentos pickled pimentos you
should talk about
if you were real if you were real
[ __ ] hardcore
you had some pickled pigs feet on there
too yeah we never did those but my
grandmother pickled eggs
now another thing that would be in that
um
uh deviled egg mixture would be
some kind of a relish or some kind of a
diced up pickles
and there was always these little
difference well my pickles are such and
such pickles or my thing you know
there's always somebody had their own
everyone's gotta fight
mine's like that i don't use pickles i'm
using diced cucumber
you know and just [ __ ] like that you
know man then once they're all done on
the plate you dust them
dust them with um paprika paprika and
chill them they have to be chilled
although some people do like them hot
they're better chilled
i think so yeah you can put a little bit
tabasco sauce on them but pop them down
it's funny because when i was growing up
i liked fried eggs but i wasn't a big
hard-boiled egg fan
i think it was in when i got older
because i wouldn't even
really eat deviled eggs i'd be like oh
gross you know what i mean but like i
like fried eggs but not anything else
yeah but when i got older i was just
kind of like what the [ __ ] was i even
thinking these things are [ __ ]
delicious
one of the reasons why it became so
popular in southern cooking is like i
said these people had sharecropper
roots you know even the king elvis
presley his parents were sharecrop
usually at least one of those families
on that block
had a chicken coop a lot of them had
several chicken coops and i mean
between four houses maybe two of them
had chicken coops
and just traded eggs for other stuff
like yeah give me some walnuts just some
eggs
you know so eggs were just abundant if
you have
some chickens you got more eggs than you
can eat
so you got to do something with them but
you're making bread i mean honestly i
love eggs yeah they're good yeah
and i mean we go to sam's and buy that
big [ __ ] car that big [ __ ] up
carton of it big we buy big crates of
eggs because we go through a lot of eggs
go through a lot of eggs
and it's just cheaper to buy them in
bass well you can do so much [ __ ] with
them and they're like they're
actually really nutritious and you know
they're really versatile
yeah and they're not real fattening and
they're real filling
i got these water pots you can put water
in there and turn it on into the boiled
water for making tea and stuff yeah like
everybody in the uk
but in the u.s it's not real common not
real coffee we have one though
what i'll do is i'll take a dozen eggs
and put them in there and fill it up
full of water turn it on let them boil
and it shuts itself off just let it sit
there yeah
come back 20 minutes later and you'll
have perfectly hard-boiled eggs inside
that thing pour all the water out
you don't have to watch them yeah yeah
and put them in the refrigerator
yeah and then ever so it's like oh
breakfast time like pop out a couple
hard-boiled eggs they're already
pre-pre-boiled
and you know and then that's good too
because when you have uh
pre-hard-boiled eggs just in the fridge
you make ramen noodles you can pop that
[ __ ] in there you make some grits you
can pop that [ __ ] in there
yeah they go good and everything
pre-cooking yeah pre-cooked things that
when you can get away with it that way i
stock a pre-cooked ingredient yeah
i especially like hang up and you can
cut them up and put them on salads too i
like to do that also yep
yeah and i also like i said i really
like them in the ramen noodles yeah
um do you want to talk about i think it
was later on down the list but you
mentioned it so
um i do want to talk about pimento
cheese yes okay
here's another here's one thing that i'm
not really a fan of yeah she's not a fan
of it my grandma loved it i'll eat it
but i don't i'm not crazy about it
it didn't end up in the cookbook but no
matter
where you got about it forgot about it
it's an important
southern kind of component to things
it's called pimento cheese
pimento cheese spread okay esther said i
love your shirt jenny thank you
yeah i forgot i had this yeah i haven't
worn it in such a long time pimento
cheese is nothing more than grated
uh cheddar cheese with diced pimentos in
it
those little red things we were getting
them out of a jar
and mayonnaise yes stir it up now some
people will add certain kind of spices
all right they might put cayenne pepper
in it they might put
cajun seasoning in it but the basic is
none at all
it's just grated grated
cheese use [ __ ] some type of cheddar
okay although there's variations of that
there's a bunch of recipes on there but
the basic is sharp cheddar cheese grated
bunch of diced pimentos and then
you put mayo in it and stir it and then
it stores like that you can put it back
in the refrigerator
and you spread it on toast and make a
quick sandwich
fantastic is it healthy [ __ ] no no no no
no
no
it's like it's cheese and mayonnaise
cheese tastes great
especially after it's chilled and kind
of cured for
a day in in the in there and then you
can use it as a spread on prepared
things you put on crackers and stuff
well none of that you could put it on a
hot dog you could put it on a [ __ ]
hot dog
yeah you could put it on a hamburger
it's a bunch of stuff
too all right yeah it's like a condiment
it's like a condiment maybe i could add
it but i just i could add it like in a
little condiment
box yeah my dad i'll stick it in there
my dad used to put it on top of [ __ ]
hamburgers
i'm gonna write that down so i remember
he used to put it on top of them
fried chicken sandwiches
you know what it might be good on on
something yeah
i think the reason why it's because you
made it a few times you don't have
anything
very basic yeah and it's like i remember
when i was growing up i was always just
kind of like because sometimes my
grandmother would make it or sometimes
she would buy it like it would come in
little
like a little tub like like nowadays you
get a little tub like that that has like
[ __ ] uh
yeah what do you call it uh hummus in it
yeah so it was like that
type of thing and she would just eat it
like on white bread she might toast the
bread she just ate it like that and she
just thought i was like that is so
disgusting
no but it's like but um but you made it
recently and i was like oh maybe
maybe i'll eat it and it won't be the
same as when i was a kid because you
know there was a lot of [ __ ] i wouldn't
eat it as a kid that now is good
but i still couldn't get behind it but i
could probably get behind it
because i like all three of the
components yeah
but i think that i just don't like it it
seems too blue like it on its own
on its own like on a sandwich i don't
want that that seems kind of yucky
but putting it on fried chicken or like
a burger or something
that would probably be good yeah i mean
it'd be southern classic
yeah now there's other things that kind
of come and go
some of these things stick and some of
these things don't
and everybody knows you know tea can
back me up on this
most southern cooking at one time or
another started off as soul food
yeah something black people invented all
right the white peoples who went yeah
that's good and then they incorporated
it yeah give us some of this it went the
other way too
it was there was you know what i mean it
went both ways
but the thing right now that i'm not
sure i can get on board with it's
this thing is this is some missy
mississippi [ __ ] as hell
all right they're making videos about it
and i'm going like i don't know if i'm
on board with that
black people taking basically a
fried fish sandwich like a like a flayer
fish right
and putting um cookies and cream ice
cream on it
yeah um and they say this [ __ ] is good
as hell
and they're like yeah it it's like it's
like a it's like a fad
thing that's happening either that
they're trolling everyone
see that was the thing you see black
people make these
but they were [ __ ] at least
pretending like they liked it but
that might be a troll it has to be
cookies and cream ice cream it was
cookies and cream ice cream on a damn
filet fish sandwich basically
but it was a homemade filet of fish
okay it's weird but i'm not as grossed
out about it
as i as maybe i should be see tease
freaking
it might work it might work what the
[ __ ] fish on a
ice cream on a fish sandwich yeah that's
what they were eating
it might work and and i can't really
imagine what that would taste like black
chick was eating it and she's going this
is miss
mississippi as hell y'all and she's
[ __ ] she's going damn this is good
well [ __ ] now we're going to wait how
we're going to go where are they
trolling i don't know
that'd be funny if it was let's see if
we can get these [ __ ] peck away
packages to [ __ ] eat this but they
were eating it they look like they were
eating it
there's like pretending to eat it
so that one i'm just throwing that one
out there for you
trying to get ahead of the curve in case
that becomes a southerner
a new trend yeah just in case that
becomes a southern class that's
going to be the avocados i'm mentioning
it
because that whole concept is [ __ ]
plausible
that's [ __ ] plausible that's like
something somebody in mississippi would
eat
well i mean the thing about it because
it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah i've seen i've seen weirder
things like that you know
where it's just kind of like [ __ ] that
you wouldn't really think would go
together like especially something
that's fried like deep fried
like a deep breath and if you deep fried
fish that doesn't really have a super
super strong flavor
you know what i mean he said that's
barely ged
cuisine
but i not gonna lie i kind of want to
try it now i'm just out of curiosity
it might be onto something i could get
some fish nuggets and then i could just
put a little bit i'm not gonna buy like
a whole big thing
you would think that you would think
that fried chicken and waffles wouldn't
be good but that's
been looking at other very it's very
good very good
well we've been getting it on the bone
the chicken's on the bone yeah
i've also seen it basically in the form
of chicken tenders
on top of the waffle and then you pour a
bunch of
butter and the syrup on it yeah that way
it's easier to get a cut
yeah where you get chicken and waffles
and everything and the syrup and the
butter on the same
fork full you know what i mean that way
you know you have to debone it
right you know it looks a lot better
because
you wouldn't think that that's good but
as soon as you have it you go oh no
that's very good it makes a lot of sense
when you taste it
yeah it's like i think people initially
i mean not so much nowadays because it's
kind of proliferated
but i think when chicken and waffles
first started kind of like filtering
into the mainstream consciousness
i think a lot of people are like what
chicken and wobbles what the [ __ ]
but it's like all waffles are it's just
a quick bread
yeah it's bread and fried chicken people
have been putting honey
on fried chicken like forever and that's
really good like
sweet sauces like sweet sauces and meat
goes together
so it's like it's not as weird as it
initially seems no the uh
the um if you've ever had honey on
chicken
then you will instantly like maple syrup
on chicken yeah because it tastes
pretty very close if anything i think
the maple kana
is an enhancement over the honey because
it kind of blends in with the seasoning
in the
in the uh the crust yeah and the bread
and crust you're like oh okay
because it makes more sense when it
comes in contact with salt
yeah they go whoa there's a resident
frequency that comes out of it
oh yeah and then you have the bread
along with it but it's a fried bread
and the the texture is perfect for that
chicken grease and it's perfect for the
um what do you call it the maple syrup
to be inside that bread you're expecting
it to be in that bread it all just
blends perfectly
yeah it's only strange when you first
kind of hear it if you just think about
it yeah
then it sounds weird because i thought
when i was a kid the first time i heard
about it i'm like what that sounds
really weird
although then i didn't really think then
i was like well wait a minute when i was
a little kid we used to love those eggo
waffles yeah just being 11 from stranger
things
but um we would we used to make
sandwiches out of that
you know what i mean he just going i
can't see real black people eat
what's the educational system like him
barely ged cuisine
and she's going i'd rather eat a pod out
of the invasion of the body snatchers
i don't you know what though i'm kind of
like thinking about maybe for science
i might try it out but don't if it's not
good like don't tell them i gotta look
back into it you know
maybe somebody other people have
reviewed it and they now they're [ __ ]
with us
you know what i mean well here's the
thing though i feel like for a while i
don't know if it's such a thing anymore
but for a while there was kind of a
trend of doing like weird ass ice cream
flavors it's like oh was it bacon ice
cream it's this that the other thing
and um you know it's fish flavored ice
cream and a lot of that was just like
you know stunt food
yeah um just to get publicity or
whatever but some of them
like turned out kind of good yeah it had
the bun
you could see the fillet the fish fillet
in there
and then on on top of it i could see
like a smashed scoop of cookies and
cream ice cream
and it's dripping out of there and i
could see she was holding it in big
long fingernails
[Laughter]
they were eating it
[Laughter]
i don't know maybe it's good maybe i'm
not gonna hate it maybe there's
something about the salt there was
cheese on it too so maybe there's
something about the saltiness
of the fish and the cheese mixing with
the sweet cool
creaminess of the ice cream it's almost
like sweet tarts
the educational system what's the
educational system in like in
mississippi
okay it's a trip depends on where you
live
it's kind of self-segregated the public
schools are pretty much all black uh
you can google uh heidelberg high school
uh and that was the one that was right
near my dad's house and when i grew up
that's and it looks like a beautiful
high school
okay you have to understand the country
parts of mississippi
black people are experiencing the 1950s
it's like something out of happy days
they got their own cars they date they
they live in all the towns nice little
towns they got the high school
and it's the high school's just like all
black there's no white people that live
in those areas
but it's nice real nice you'll see and
uh they go to the army and the military
and
come back home and it's it's like that's
it's pretty much all american
uh it's also kind of religious there's
baptist churches
um the crime rate is extremely low
um it's it's black mayberry all right
the white kids now are all gone my dad
is the last white guy in heidelberg
mississippi that's my understanding and
they take care of him you know
he was dying of a heart attack on his
front porch and the neighbors across the
street grabbed him and
got him out of there and visited him in
the hospital everybody gets along it's
it's not what you would think yeah
southerners base southerners in the
country basically get along
um but it when there were
white kids there which they've all grown
and gone
they went to a place called heidelberg
academy which is a little private school
um but there was maybe
the total amount of kids that went to
that school there might have been 60 of
them
at any one time going and that was and
that was like
from kindergarten to high school they're
like a total of 60 of them
so you talk about a little tiny school
yeah yeah
tila said the oddest ice cream flavor
we've tried was garlic ice cream
yeah i remember there being kind of a
thing for that like at the garlic
festival she said it's not bad after
you've eaten garlic all day yeah
and then camp guy said he used to work
at captain d's every now and then
i get a hankering for captain d's we
have one probably about seven or eight
miles from here
and uh man sometimes you just want to go
up there and get some fried green
tomatoes and
some [ __ ] fried ass fish and some
hush puppies and [ __ ] like that
and then tina goes yeah i think
mississippi has the highest black
population
yes it is it's the blackest state it's i
think it's
33 percent but they're um
some of them are concentrated in jackson
the rest of them are spread
spread about around uh central
mississippi
in kind of like villages
but they're they used to be german towns
german villages like heidelberg but
all those people died and their
descendants moved away
there's just no jobs there so that's
usually what ends up happening
everybody ends up moving away i predict
that those black people
when they graduate from high school over
time they will just move away
and they're kind of being replaced by
vietnamese and people from mexico
there aren't any industries to keep
large populations there
so you're always going to be limited in
what you can do
in the in a place like that until
industries move in
but i don't think that'll happen uh
the biggest industry would be masonite
corporation and they're logging
so industrialization is not
something those big corporations would
want they want to use that as logging
territory they don't want to build
things
you know yeah so it's a very different
uh
life it's a good life uh it's uh the
people
in general are raised to be kind of
traditional
and kind of conservative and moral and
upstanding whether black or white
um the what it's the white people from
that area are kind of like
the closest thing that they'd be kind of
like south african boars
they're kind of like that even though
they're not really a minority but
they're
they're kind of like that it's kind of
like they're white people living in a
black country
it's kind of what they think of
themselves as but but they're the
majority though it just
seems like that from their point of view
tila said her paternal grandparents are
from
jackson mississippi yeah my
grandmother's biracial it was very hard
for her growing up
yeah they migrated to illinois because
there was no jobs in mississippi for
them no no
yeah that's the big problem in jackson
is that
there's no industry to support jackson
um jackson is becoming kind of like a
miniature version of detroit
you have to get out of there there's no
reason for a big city there
and uh if if you're the kind of person
that is not willing to move
you're going to be trapped there the
only place that has a future in
mississippi is biloxi gulfport you know
the gulf region where the casinos are
the rest of it it's going to be country
life from here on out if you're a farmer
but it's just that state is not going to
be an industrial it's just not worth it
it's it's it's
it's rural yeah it's country yeah like i
said it would be
farmers and people that like retired out
there yeah right
and they want to keep it that way camp
guy says my dad always used to take
fresh cucumbers and onions and soak them
in vinegar and serve them in small
crudite traits yeah
yeah we always had that kind of kind of
that kind of stuff too so what's next on
the list
i think barbecue is next barbara knows
about barbecue that's what i'm saying
so let me scroll down a little bit
there's deviled eggs barbecue
country ham everybody knows about that
shrimp and grits
all right you talk about [ __ ] shrimp and
grits shrimp and grits is
grits with shrimp in it the of your
choice
okay what else well i think we talked
about shrimp and grits a lot because i
posted that picture on instagram of
getting it at chantals and it was like
out of this [ __ ] world it was so
[ __ ] good
yeah they don't have that at night
though they only have that in the
daytime i think the next thing was fried
green tomatoes
okay yeah fried green tomatoes all right
those share croppers a lot of what they
grew out in the back of that house with
tomatoes
yeah because tomatoes will grow all over
the south and it's really really easy to
grow
easy to grow and you have a lot of them
the problem is is that you can't eat a
tomato until it's ripe
well you might be hungry and it might
have a lot of green tomatoes and i'm
gonna wait for this [ __ ] this you know
bowls [ __ ] made
[ __ ] i'm hungry now i'm not gonna
wait another three months for these
suckers to get red
so you can go out there and take some of
them and pick them because they're big
they're still the size by apple
okay so you're gonna pick them anyway
but if you eat them they're [ __ ]
terrible that first of all they're too
hard
and they're kind of bitter but you can
fix that if you
if you slice them thinly and fry them
batter them
roll them in cornmeal and fry them and
now you've got something you can eat and
it tastes kind of like fried zucchini
yeah that'd be the best way to describe
it like they do okra kind of like that
too
which is pretty much the only way that
i'll eat okra yeah although okra has a
very different texture
it's more it's a lot closer to fried
zucchini
yeah and uh you could eat that with a
piece of ham or a piece of meat or
anything and then have a dessert some
cobbler after it and you you know
knocked down three or four of these
fried tomatoes and they were fried in
bacon grease so they have a nice flavor
and
they had some cornmeal on them and you
felt like you ate a meal
is it nutritious not really
but it did fill you up and you ate it
with some other stuff you ate it with
some protein and yeah
it's better than not eating and that was
some protein like you said there's some
vegetables
in there yeah you eat it with a piece of
ham you know
maybe you had some country fried steak
which is
some cube steak [ __ ] beating out and
flat
and [ __ ] god we ate so much cube
steak yeah
the southern version of filet mignon was
[ __ ] cube steak which is cheap
i mean puff super cheap super cheap
super tough meat
beef how do you eat that well you could
braise it you could slow cook it but
that takes a long time
yeah all right you're trying to cook a
piece of meat
right now and eat it 10 minutes from now
how do you do that well you cut off a
piece
about this big you put it on a a cutting
board
and you pound it with a hammer amount
you know one of those tenderizers
both sides beating salt and pepper into
it too
then you take it you might hit it with a
little bit of egg batter
or egg wash throw it in some seasoned
flour
uh and then throw those pieces in a pan
fry them up
one side then the other bacon grease put
it on a biscuit
pour some gravy on it eat it fantastic
done and done done and done right that's
right
and uh it's a flavorful chewy
but it's not um tough because you
you powdered it with the with the
tenderizer and it's uh
kind of like a deep fried hamburger
kinda no like a deep fried steak that's
the best way
it is kind of like a hamburger yeah
esther brought up chicken fried steak
which we i guess we could yeah it's just
it's a similar kind of thing that's kind
of what we're talking about it's just
the chicken fried steak
usually has that white that gravy on it
graveyard yeah white gravy on top of it
but yeah it's the same kind of thing
where you just like beat the hell out of
them yeah the white gravy is just a back
of a base
flour based gravy it's used bacon grit
drippings with some butter you fry some
some um uh uh when you've got flour in
there you make a light roux
pour cream in it if i can bring it out
to a nice white and
this now during all that time you had
the cracked peppercorns usually in some
salt so you want some black pepper in it
maybe a little bit of cayenne if you
want some flavor and you pour that over
anything
anything pour it over grits pour it over
a hard boil or
what do you call them scrambled eggs
over an omelette
whatever yeah that's your southern
omelette right there because you have
gravy on it
i'm just laughing because the name
chicken fried steak is like really funny
because i remember like
when i was talking to some british
people or they were here and like they
were looking at a menu
and they're like chicken fried steak
what does that mean
like you know what i mean it's like is
it chicken is it steak is it nothing i
had to explain i'm like no it's
beef but it's fried like chicken is
fried
i don't know it's like it's a very
confusing name you know what i mean
you're gonna fry it like you fried
chicken yes
exactly but it's steak they're tricking
you with words
[Laughter]
what's not in there uh so we talked
about fried green spanish pecan pie
yeah pecan pie we we used to eat it a
lot pecan pie it's a very you know eggs
pecans
sugar and then a homemade pie crust
which is easy you know
it could use usually it's flour and
mayonnaise
you can turn that into a crust and then
you put it in there because it's got
everything you need for a mayonnaise
thank you [ __ ] cook it cook the crust
first pull it back out
pour the to see what it was it was
actually
you put in a bunch of pecans and you
could pour maple syrup or carbo syrup in
it
and some eggs went and eggs he had beat
up some eggs i think
it's been a while since i've seen the
recipe and then bake it
and um beautiful beautiful
great with ice cream or whipped cream
but pecan pie yeah pretty pretty much
i'm
unbeatable uh a lot of places in
mississippi you can just find pecans
laying on the ground as long as the
deers don't get them
you go to the pecan tree you know when
pecans are laying on the ground because
there's
you're going to see deer out there
because the deer also know
because pecans are delicious yeah you
might want to chase them [ __ ] off and
go through all that
i can make a pie yeah you could tell
them once they haven't eaten you know
they're still closed
you could go up in there in the tree and
pull on some of them down too you know
you make pie with that we always at
thanksgiving we always do a pumpkin pie
and a pecan pie
yeah or sweet potato pie too yeah you
can do sweet potato pie also
yeah i think the next thing on the list
was chicken fried steak but we already
talked we were talking about
yeah chicken fried steak that was the
next thing pimento cheese we were
talking about
pralines pralines yeah okay problems
that's butter and sugar turned into a
candy
basically butter and sugar um
and um picard yeah pecans
yeah picard yeah you need wax paper for
it
you make this stuff it's almost kind of
like a
um you cook it in a pot you're almost
making car it's basically making caramel
it's a very primitive caramel and you
put some
pecans in a little pile in your port you
put them on a pile on top of your wax
paper and you pour that on it drizzle it
on there
with uh you know a ladle and uh it'll
cool
and they'll cool into uh little things
that'll come off the little candies
yeah all right they're most commonly
found in the united states broken up
and inside ice cream called prawns and
cream ice cream
and you can put pralines inside of a
bowl and pour cream on them and eat them
you eat them like cereals
[Laughter]
diabetes yeah
[Laughter]
and it's it's cooked sugar i mean it's
kind of you know they're
they're they're on the verge of being a
little bit grainy
you know um if it's done right they'll
have a little bit of texture to them
uh they're delicious the recipe is
pretty easy i'm just off the top of my
head i don't remember all the all the
little steps you had to do
they're easy to make cheap and delicious
and real bad for you
they are real bad for you camp guy says
have you ever made microwave peanut
brittle i was it's funny because i was
just gonna mention peanut brittle
i didn't even know you can make it in a
microwave i've made it from scratch
before but it's been a long time and i
burned it a little bit but it was still
good
i really really like peanut brittle too
i mean and pretty much anything
like dessert wise with nuts in it [ __ ]
man i'll put pecans or peanuts or stuff
like that on pretty much anything
i put them on salads i put it on
everything can't guy think thinks
it's a hot mixture of sugar molasses and
pecans that sounds about right
yeah yeah there's variations yeah but
yeah you can make it i mean
i thought it was butter was in there too
there's variations
we have to see but they're the recipes
are online
you can just choose one there's classic
ones and then people are going to dress
that up
there's another one that's probably not
here um
my grandmother used to make them they
were called cocoons
yeah i might yeah remember those yeah i
think i had my mom made cocoons were a
little
little cookies shaped like a little
cocoon
and they were little shortbread cookies
that had
walnuts inside of them ground up fine
walnuts and they were rolled in powdered
sugar and they had a lot of butter in
them the butter would seep out of the
cookie and go into the powdered sugar
and make almost kind of like a
like a glaze like a glaze on them they
were
if you guys have ever had those sugar
lemon cookies those lemon drop cookies
they were like that but instead of lemon
they were
they were little uh they're walnut i
think they were walnuts they're the
walnut pecan
i could eat my wheat they're another one
that was real common that we used to
have it was called
um i think it was called ambrosia
ambrosa salad that's a bit that's kind
of big in the midwest too
i've heard it had mandarin oranges uh i
think
pineapple coconut yeah that's shredded
coconut shredded coke
and coconut cherries and you kind of
would stir it up in a mixture of
it was whipped mayonnaise and whipped um
there's a cool whip
i think we usually use cool you could
use cool whip but i i don't think that's
what we used i think it was a mixture of
mayonnaise and
um cream cheese yeah and then it had
many more once it was whipped you mixed
it up in there and then you put mini
marshmallows in it
yeah gosh [ __ ] was good man
it was real good that seemed like a
light somebody would always bring that
like for thanksgiving
really good because it's super easy to
make you just like open up a couple cans
of like fruit open up
yeah a bag of like sweetened coconut
pieces
yeah sounds kind of gross but it's
chilled it's real cold when you get it
it's
and it's you put it in a bowl and it's
just a
kind of cross between a gelatin dessert
well there's no gelatin in it but it's
kind of like something you could get
with
like ice cream kind of a yeah
but not quite not it's not quite not as
dense and there's like a lot of fruit in
it yeah and some people do like a
variation that's green
as well yeah yeah and i'm not sure if
they've just put green food
coloring in it or if it's like pistachio
or something like that i don't know what
they put in the green one we never had a
green one but i've seen other people no
they wanted ones
another one i saw a lot was that lemon
icing bundt cake it was a round cake
with a hole in the middle of it with
lemon icing on it it was a lemon
it was like yeah deep lemon cake with
the monkey oh man
and they would just take pure lemon
juice and mix it with icing sugar and
pour it on the top
and that's that it was lemony it would
send you through the roof it was [ __ ]
beautiful real heavy dense moist cake
i really love lemon yeah anything
obviously
yeah esther city ambrosia salad is big
where i live in philadelphia is it
yeah i'm pretty sure like that might
have i don't know if it's like an out
west thing but i'm pretty sure i know
the midwest had a big thing with it and
it's a southern thing a lot
yeah and southerners eat that yeah you
know so i guess like
mid-atlantic i guess is kind of a big so
i've heard it called different things
too but i think ambrosia salad is the
most
i it's hilarious to me how like all
those mid-century
cookbooks they would call this stuff
salad that was clearly not a salad
you know what i mean it was just like
let's let's put like cut up some carrots
and put them in jello and like make a
jello mold out of it and it's like they
call that
these foods are like reliving my
childhood right yeah yeah
yeah this is like what we grew up eating
man yeah
that uh i can't believe we lived as long
as we did
i know my dad my dad when he was a baby
on a bottle
they were giving him milk but there was
also a bunch of bacon grease they put in
there
that's what they were like thank you
make it big and strong
make that big yeah every one of them
every little bottle they gave my dad
probably had like a teaspoon of [ __ ]
bacon fat in it
that was just the way they were man they
would think all that make him healthy
yeah
man they probably [ __ ] lock you up
for [ __ ] child abuse doing that
nowadays
probably they would bacon grease you
know what you're trying to do
babies can't eat that yeah well you know
they can eat it it's just the [ __ ]
you're gonna clog that baby's artery
tonight
that's the beauty of that yeah it was
the thinking of the time
i guess yeah they weren't really strong
and healthy
another thing that i was thinking of
that we had at holidays a lot was gooey
butter cake i've also seen it called
ooey gooey butter cake i don't remember
that one
but uh my grandma used to make it it's
so
so good but seriously you can only eat
one or two pieces a year because it's
like really really really rich
um but we'd always like try to make my
grandma make it
for thanksgiving well she'd always make
it for christmas but we always try to
like talk her to make it for
thanksgiving too but she would always
act like it was this big ordeal like she
didn't want to do it
but then she would usually do it anyway
but um it's just
you you can make it i mean you can make
it from scratch obviously but
a lot of people make it with boxed uh
cake mixes but then you add stuff to it
yeah and then you like it's really
really good it's like it's kind of a
thin
it's more of a bar than a cake really um
but it's really really
rich and then you eat it with like um
powdered sugar on the top it's really
really good
gina said people were using bacon
grease's facial moisturizer too
yeah that probably works they were also
putting mayonnaise in their hair
as conditioner yeah leave it in there
and hold it in there for a while
hey anything and then they rip it all
out and you'd have your hair all [ __ ]
moisturized yeah that was the thing
chicks did though
guys didn't care about that that's my
mayo hair
[Laughter]
yeah dom the bombs like bacon fat and
milk with a little puking emoji
oh yeah keto baby yeah it's like a keto
baby yeah you know maybe
well uh in that in my dad's generation
if a baby was fat then it was healthy
well yeah that's what you wanted you
want a little scrawny ass baby you
wanted
a big but you wanted a big bowling ball
though
you need a big substantial baby yeah he
gonna grow big
don't grow big he's the size of a
butterball turkey all the way
yeah he gonna be a bigon
that is totally how they thought like
honestly they were
in a way like i said it's not good but
if you weren't eating a lot
they thought there was something that
mattered with you yeah and the idea the
id
the the idea of that generation is that
the more
fuel you threw into that fire that was
the baby
the taller and the more healthy and
stronger it would grow like a tree
which kind of made it had the truth it
was like a tree
like a tree so and you want what what
did you want to give him something
that'll make him gain
weight yeah so yeah bacon grease
[Laughter]
because you can grow out this way dude
come out like this and then he'll go
like that
he's got all that fuel in there launch
him up like a rocket
you know that was the thinking this is
kind of a magical thinking
so the south was full of magical
thinking oh yeah
yeah that's part of the culture yeah i
remember like i told you i think i've
told this story before my grandmother
she was like uh she was real thin
amazingly even though she ate like that
her whole entire life because she was
from tennessee
but uh she never got over 120 pounds her
whole entire life
but uh she famously would not drink
anything other than coca-cola
yeah she drank coca-cola with every
single meal she
and she used to think i was weird
because i didn't like i didn't drink
soda
i would just drink like water and milk
and she'd be like don't drink water
that's bad for you
so it'll it'll rush your pipe she said
she used to tell me when i was little
what was funny is that you know ever you
know growing up going
into mississippi to visit my dad every
summer and then going back to california
to live with my mom up until you know
1981 you know which i was about when i
was
i guess i left about 15 something like
that 14 15.
there was a difference between kids in
california and kids in mississippi big
big time in the build yeah big time
kids in california were just kind of
medium build kind of you know slender
athletic type
you know because they were active and
they kind of had a little bit more of a
normal diet and then
in in the like i said they were more
suburban you know yeah so they had
suburban
standards on things mississippi was
weird in in
in the 70s in the 80s it was
something kind of like out of one of
those b movies you know
uh they were it was extremes in some
ways
in ways either they were really scrawny
they look like they were [ __ ]
malnourished or fat
or just corn fed healthy
corn fed women you know which looks good
on a 15 16 17 year old you know but by
the time 22 comes around a lot of those
times a lot of times they were
overweight
but when they were teenagers they looked
real good
you know because your skin your skin
tone is strong enough to support weight
you know it kind of set at gravity it
didn't start
taking over so there it was kind of
funny they did they're
looking back on it they did kind of have
extremes
which you didn't see in suburban
california
yeah like i said i think on the west
coast even you know
even up to nowadays there tends to be a
more active outdoor lifestyle you know
so especially like up in washington
oregon like everybody's like riding
bikes and climbing mountains and [ __ ]
like that
so i don't think the the obesity rate is
as
plus they eat like you said they eat a
different it's a different diet out
there because they were physically
active in mississippi they were not
playing they were doing stuff it's just
what they were eating some of them
weren't eating anything of any
nutritional value
and they were just really skinny that
was a big problem other ones were
eating stuff that was like i said you
know real heavy and bacon grease and
cheese and mayonnaise and stuff so they
get overweight krispy kreme doughnuts
krispy kreme doughnuts
they were running around but they were
they were getting fat some of them
looked kind of like those girls that i
was showing you that were on [ __ ]
tests where they were [ __ ]
big yeah big bones but their bodies were
supporting it you know
like like uh uh what you know what a
black dude would call it becky
you know lots
you know yeah yeah tila says she got
them big legs yeah very popular saying
with older southern men
yeah big legs big hips big boobs
actually
like my current my time
yeah yeah he like he likes them i like a
becky look
with the big old boobs and a bigger ass
yeah
i like a woman i like the proportions
that frank frazetta would
would would draw like that
i think the last thing on the list uh
unless you want to
think of something else is the cornbread
yeah cornbread
i don't think there's much to say about
cornbread other than most people who've
had cornbread outside the south has have
had
only fake cornbread last time i went to
mississippi i even found fake cornbread
in mississippi
my dad was just going god this ain't no
[ __ ] corn but this ain't cornbread
this is that yankee corn cake okay you
know it's much sweeter
yeah because southern cornbread is not i
mean the corn cake is good too
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
outside the south mississippi and
louisiana alabama they've
they've they've they've sanitized
cornbread into something that y'all
foreigners can eat
they've made it like like a corn
flavored sweet cake
you know and then they'll give you some
butter that has had
whipped butter that has uh honey in it
to even make it sweeter that is not
cornbread
cornbread is only about an inch thick
maybe a little bit more than an inch
thick it's
it's it's basically unleavened it's very
dry
and very gritty and coarse that's
cornbread
it's designed to sop up [ __ ] pot
liquor and things like
you know like things out of your damn
collard greens and
uh uh your red eye green red eye gravy
it's meant to absorb things and it had
its own consistency it was i think it
started off as something
out of necessity probably civil war
where there
all they had was cornmeal and like a
couple of things like maybe some lard
and from that you try to make something
to eat make some kind of bread out of
that
it's almost like more related to a stack
of corn tortillas one on top of the
other
not quite but
it's i would say it's bad
real cornbread is kind of bad unless you
grew up eating it and yeah it's one of
those things in context
yeah you have to see it in the context
of the meal that you were being given
you know that you to go along with it
it's a side
it's something you're dipping into a
bowl and you might have a bunch of
collard greens and the juice from the
collard greens and you're
dipping the slice of cornbread in there
and getting it out of there like that
you know
becky loves it
do you guys remember i don't know if you
ever had these but every now and then we
would have
because a lot of times when my grandma
would make cornbread but she didn't feel
like making it
they also sell these cornbread squares
they were about the size
yeah they're about the size of like a
regular slice of you know white bread or
whatever
but they were just like perfectly square
they were a bit sweeter
but we usually had those she would kind
of pop those in the oven and then like
make those with the
she'd have that with like the country
ham or whatever yeah um then they're
talking about
uh hush puppies which are also delicious
yeah [ __ ] yeah hush puppies hush puppies
are a modified cornbread
they just dropped in pretty much yeah
into the
into the what do you call it um they're
basically cooked in uh
fish juice or it's bacon and fish
they're frying bacon in
but they're frying fish in bacon grease
and then after the fish is fried you're
dropping in spoonfuls of basically
corn seasoned cornbread mix with some
other stuff in it to make a hush puppy
so it's a mixture of bacon and fish
oils have cooked that hush puppy if the
fish wasn't involved you'd never really
have a real hush puppy the idea was you
threw those to the dogs
to keep to keep them satisfied yeah
that's why they're called hodgepodge
yeah because
dogs are barking
yeah right but then they realized they
were good so they started like never
mind people do this for myself the dog
can't have it yeah
and the dogs are like mirror
[Laughter]
oh my god i thought i was gonna say
something but i forgot uh
what it was something to do with i don't
know if it was anything to do with hush
puppies oh no i was gonna say
um do you guys i don't even know if they
still sell this but when you're making
cornbread
did everybody's like moms and grandmas
he's like that jiffy
cornbread mix yeah it was like white is
it white on the front like blue on the
side
yeah and then uh yeah my grandma always
had like a bunch it was quick and easy
to use they used that
yeah in the cabinet that was all that
was always she always had tons of them
you had to be careful because back in
the
back in the late 70s and in the 80s even
in the 80s i remember that the jiffy
cornbread mix
would arrive already with bull weevils
in it sometimes
yeah remember that you had to check it i
think we did have that happen once or
twice now that you're mentioning it i've
forgotten all about that
yeah they'd get pissed it's already got
the goddamn butt oh it wasn't
[Laughter]
that's my last box god damn it now i
gotta go back to the winn-dixie yeah
yeah you go get some more of them and
two of them already have [ __ ] weebles
in them
they were getting infected at the jiffy
factory yeah that was back then though
it's probably not like that anymore yeah
i said i had forgotten about that but
now that you remained it i do remember
that happening when i was a kid
yeah like not super frequently but every
now and then yeah
um but yeah i think that's probably all
the food we got to talk about yeah oh i
did want to say too
because uh we didn't stream yesterday
we had a little minor uh disaster with
beijing yesterday
yeah you tell that one oh my goodness
well
what happened was like tom comes rushing
into the office he's like yeah
he's in beijing's eye hurry her eye pops
out yeah
i'm like what what yeah like and he was
like i don't know if she ran into
something like it looks like her eyes
gone oh my god
yeah that's not what it was though no
well yeah they ended up like
when when we looked at it closely when
you looked at it more closely it was
this
what they call it conjunct it's
conjunctive
it was a piece of flap a flap of like an
inner lid that would cover the eye
i thought it was a damage to the lens
but when i went back and looked at it
again it wasn't
yeah because i think he looked at it
really quick yeah her eyes gone
yeah yeah yeah you know i mean because
she was sitting there it was it was it
was
she had it kind of closed and it was
tearing and she was coming to me for
help
and i said what do you got and i opened
it up and i jumped back and she looked
at me like oh it's got to be bad
so found the local the the nearest one
here
i knew she knew that it was bad because
i brought the damn cat carrier and she
didn't run from it
she stayed right there and i came back
later
put her inside the cat carrier after i
put a new
towel in the bottom of it because i
don't know why but
the the towel from her last visit was
still in there so i put a new one in
there
and she'd even jump out she's like yeah
i need to go to the doctor you know she
knew she never
mastered her but it wasn't anything
major then they put her ass on steroids
she's running around running around
[ __ ] she's on performance enhancing
drugs yeah she's totally like well
she's running all over the house and i'm
like i know exactly how you feel baby
yeah yeah yeah like her eye looks so
much better like compared to yesterday
but yeah it's conjunctivitis which is
very very common in cats
it's just that i didn't see her and then
like tom just comes running and i was
going yeah her eye's gone
like he was wigging out and i was like
what don't you do what i was like
freaking out i thought like
maybe pookie had like poked her in the
eye or she ran i thought she hit
something or yeah or like ran into
something in the house or like a
plant or something outside from the
inside of the eyes
the swelling and it looked like a down
piece of the limb it looks
bad if you look up like uh pictures of
conjunctivitis
yeah most of them don't look bad but
then i hit one it goes yeah that's it
that's it right there yeah
well actually it'll a lot of times they
said it'll go away on its own but
obviously they like to give
uh you know the kitty medicine so it
doesn't hurt them and stuff
but then it's funny because uh so this
morning
to beijing was like feeling a little bit
better but i was like well let's just
let her convalesce or whatever
and she was sitting on the dining room
chair which she likes to like underneath
the tablecloth
and all you can see of her is her little
foofy tail like hanging down
so i'm in the kitchen making coffee and
i see pookie like come around the corner
like all
shifty and then she looks at me and then
she looks at beijing's tail
hanging there and she's like and then
she looks at me and i'm like
don't you do it i said she's not feeling
good don't you [ __ ] with her tail
and pookie's like yeah yeah
and i was and then she kept looking at
me i'm like don't you do it yeah don't
you do it because she was
she really really she was like and she
kept going yeah
like she really really wanted to like go
over and [ __ ] with her tail
but she did it the end i got to make
sure the ice maker is working i've been
[ __ ] with this damn ice maker for two
days yeah our ice maker on our approach
yeah
it wasn't working right i think i got it
right now the thing wasn't pushed in the
right way
yeah i think it's what it was yeah tila
said oh she just needs antibiotics right
yeah yeah she yeah she's on antibiotics
and she's got eye drops and she's almost
done
that steroid like to make her feel
better so yeah she's been like jumping
off the walls
yeah today she tried and she even like
tried to like escape when i
uh went to take garbage out she was like
i was like hey get your ass back
in here she came back in like right when
i said it though i was like get your ass
back in there she's like okay
she's just got a lot of energy she's
feeling good yeah that's good i was just
like
i'm so glad because i was really alarmed
i thought she
her little eye popped out but yeah so uh
we'll be back tomorrow probably talking
about
uh a movie one of two i haven't i don't
know which one we're gonna watch but we
have a couple lined up
so oh uh time you gonna say bye yeah i'm
gonna say bye but i gotta uh i'm gonna
check the ice maker
okay all right so we'll be back uh
tomorrow at three o'clock so have a good
rest of your weekend
and we'll see you later bye